NISHANT PATNI: My
name is Nishant Patni.
I'm the founder and
CEO of Hello English.
It's an app that helps
millions of Indians
learn English in a
fun and engaging way,
using gamification.
The idea of Hello English
came about when I was actually
studying in China and
trying to backpack
around surviving as a vegetarian
without speaking Mandarin.
It made me realize that
the problem was far worse
for Indians trying to learn
English, a language which
has become critical to
professional success today.
India is a bountifully
diverse country,
with 22 languages recognized
by the government.
But English is the
preferred business language.
All large businesses
prefer to use English.
PRANSHU BHANDARI:
I'm Pranshu Bhandari.
I'm the co-founder
of Hello English app.
We wanted to make
English learning
fun, convenient, and affordable,
because it could really
empower millions
of Indians to be
able to learn English
right on their smartphones.
Hello English supports over 15
Indian languages, 12 of which
have native phone
support on Android.
A key goal of the app is to
help people speak in English,
and Google's text
to speech engine
makes it quite easy for us.
Ever since they introduced
the Indian English accent,
our weekly retention
rates grew by over 18%.
Our users face
certain typical issues
quite early on-- poor
internet connectivity devices
with low storage capacity,
low processing power.
We decided to focus
our efforts entirely
on optimizing our
app for these issues.
We discovered that Google has a
bunch of tools that can really
help developers to optimize
their apps for emerging
markets like India.
We reduced the app
size from 16 MB
to 9 MB, which immediately
reduced our uninstall rate
by 15%.
Also, the majority of
the features of the app
can actually work
without any internet.
NISHANT PATNI: Today, we have
more than 13 million people
who are learning English
on Hello English,
from not just India
but around the world.
We [INAUDIBLE] to
expanding geographically
into several of the emerging
markets which face a similar
need to learn English.
More than anything else, we're
encouraged by the stories
that we hear from our learners
and how our efforts are
transforming their lives.